[Music]
I love you stupid I love you too
we'll hit the floor fans get justice for
xud at the end of season 3 we obviously
saw that someone catched a bouquet that
we saw a lot of romance throughout the
season and fans fell in love with this
couple so will we have any justice in
the form of flashbacks in the form of
reuniting you're going for the jugular
this season is definitely interesting
cuz we touched apart let's what you just
mentioned we were 0 and I were anointed
king and king of LA and Jude was a
promoted to EVP for the Devils
organizations I feel like not only for
Jude but all these characters have an
incredible arc this year and were we're
touching on territory that we hadn't
explored yet we absolutely love zero we
love Adam who plays zero Adam had a
different path that he wanted to take
other things that he wanted to do but
we're really I was very excited that
Brent was able and happy and thrilled to
come back and frankly as a show and or
have rewarded him with a killer story
which will allow the audience to
experience Jude in a totally new way so
I mean really that is going to be a big
mystery that people are gonna have to
tune in for won't be with me the way I
want but you don't want me with anyone
else I feel bad
[Music]